Let's talk about one of my favorite subjects. Fire!
Now, it's good to think about fire from a physical security perspective as a risk.
And with any risk, the deal, the way that we want to deal with that risk is by putting in place
and mitigating controls, specifically a complete control.
And a complete control, of course, is a combination of preventive, detective, and corrective.
So, how do we prevent a fire? Well, the best way to prevent fire is to not have any combustible materials,
anything that will burn. And so, for example, in a data center, if you're bringing in new servers,
you want to make sure that you unpack the servers on the loading dock.
We've all a very combustible cardboard on the loading dock. And what are you bringing to the server room?
Just the bare metal servers. So this is a perfect example of how we try and prevent fire.
Don't have any combustible materials. Now, preventive, detective, and corrective.
If we do have a fire, the very first thing we want to be able to do is quickly as possible is detect the fire.
And that's what we're going to talk about in this module.
And then the final thing, if we have detective fire, is quickly as possible we want to try and correct a fire.
And in the next module, we'll talk about different types of fire, correction, or fire suppression systems.
So let's talk about methods we can use to detect a fire. There's three major methods that we can use.
We can use what are known as flame detectors. These are basically video cameras that look for infrared or UV light.
And so they can see the flames that are looking up from a fire.
But we want to try and detect a fire as early as possible. And if you're at the point where you've got big,
licking flames like behind me here, that's not a very good way to detect a fire as early as possible.
The next method that we can use are what are known as heat detectors.
And heat detectors are just like they sound like they're basically temperature sensors.
And they look for a rapid rise in temperature. And so you'd have these heat sensors spread around your facility.
And if one or two of them detect a rapid rise in temperature, that's a pretty good indication that you have a fire.
But again, if you're at the point where the temperature is spiking, the fire is pretty far along.
So heat detectors are not necessarily the best way to detect a fire as early as possible.
And that leads us to the last and probably most important method to detect a fire as early as possible. And that's smoke detectors.
And there's a number of different types of smoke detectors we're going to talk about here.
Let's start with what are known as ionization sensors.
Ionization sensors, the way they work, it's actually quite cool. They have a small amount of radioactive material inside the smoke detector.
And it actually ionizes particles. And these particles flow between two metal plates.
And what happens if smoke particles enter this little chamber, the smoke particles will actually disrupt the flow of ionized particles.
And therefore allow you to detect fire. So that's ionization sensors.
The next most common are what are known as photoelectric.
And again, this is kind of neat how this works. So in a photoelectric sensor, you have a light source and a sensor.
And the light source is pointed a little off angle. So it's not pointed right at the sensor.
And what happens is if smoke particles pass through the sensing chamber, the smoke particles will actually cause the light to reflect into the sensing area.
And so if the sensor suddenly picks up that light's being reflected into the sensor, that's an indication that smoke particles are passing through the sensor and you have a fire.
Now, most of the sensors that we use nowadays in homes and most common business ones are what are known as dual sensors.
And just as name implies, they're a combination of both ionization and photoelectric.
And there's one final type of smoke detection system that you should know about.
And this is the most sensitive type of system. And it's very aptly named. It's called the Vesda system, which stands for very early smoke detection apparatus.
So just as the name implies, these systems are really good at detecting a fire as early as possible.
But these systems are not commonly seen because they're very, very sensitive and they're very expensive.
So where you tend to see Vesda systems are in places like data centers and museums.
But if you ever get a question asking you, what is the best way to detect a fire as early as possible?
It's smoke detectors, look first for smoke detectors and the best type of smoke detector, Vesda.